نتحدث الليلة مع
ابنة أخت الرئيس ماري ترامب عن
محادثاتها على الشريط مع
أخت عمتها الرئيسة
هنا اثنان آخران من ماريان ترامب بيري
في إيفانكا ترامب وذروة
انفصال عائلة الرئيس
أه في ذروة سياسة الرئيس
لفصل الأسرة
وهذا  عن مكانة إيريك ترامب في
ترتيب الأسرة الرابحة
هنا ، عندما
وضع دان إيفانكا هذه
الصورة لمادونا
وعلى الإنستغرام عندما كنا ننتظر أخبار
اليوم كيف أصبح
الأطفال مألوفين من
عائلاتهم لم أستطع إلقاء اللوم عليها من قبل
نحلة سامانثا قبل
أن أتمكن من إلقاء اللوم على ما قالته في هذه الأثناء
أصبح إيريك
معتوهًا علنًا.
مفضل
من المثير للاهتمام بالنسبة لي
أن أن عمتك يبدو أنها
لديها
فكرة واضحة جدًا عن كيف
يرى الرئيس
أه بقية أعماله  الأسرة على أنها مثل
أوه أنا أفهم جيدًا مثل أم
العديد من الآباء السيئين ، آه دونالد ليس دقيقًا
بشأن أي من أطفاله يفضله ،
لذا فهذا جزء منه
وهذا شيء كان جزءًا من السرد في
الأسرة
منذ أن كانوا أطفالًا
لقد قلت إن علاقته
بأطفاله هي معاملات للغاية وأعني
أن العدسة
التي ينظر إليها كل شيء من خلال
نعم أه حصل على ذلك من جدي
الذي
رأى الحياة
والعمل وعائلته على أنها لعبة محصلتها صفر
أم تعلمون أنه لا يوجد سوى  كن
فائزًا واحدًا يخسر الآخرون ، لذا
من أجل أن تكون الفائز الذي
كان مصممًا تمامًا على
أن تكون
أنت دونالد ، تحتاج إلى معرفة كيفية تعظيم
مزاياك في أي علاقة
لديك ،
فمن المثير للاهتمام أنك تعلم ، وأعتقد
أن ريك ويلسون لديه  يُدعى الكتاب
وربما أقوم بذبح العنوان ،
لكن أه كل شيء يلمسه ترامب
يموت وهي فكرة مثيرة للاهتمام
بالنسبة لي أنه
كل شخص في مداره يبدو أنه
يضر نفسه في واحدة.  سنة أو
أخرى أنه لا أحد ينجو
من الاتصال الوثيق لفترة طويلة دون أن
يتضاءل سواء كانت سمعتهم
مصدر رزقهم
مهما كان ، وأنا أتساءل
هو أن شيئًا
ما يتردد صداه معك أعني هل
تعتقد أن هذا صحيح ،
نعم إنه أه أنت تعلم على ما أعتقد  لقد رأينا
أمثلة تلو الأخرى على
ذلك وأنت تعلم أن أبناء عمومتي ليسوا استثناءً
لهذا الاختلاف هو أنهم يعرفون أفضل
من معظم الناس
، وأعتقد أن جاريد
كوشنر مدرج أيضًا في هذا في هذا الأمر ،
فهم يعرفون أفضل من أي شخص
كيف يفعلون ذلك.  تلاعب بدونالد من أجل
البقاء في نعمه الطيبة
حتى تعرف أن هذا هو سبب وجودهم
على الجانب الآخر ، ولكن ما الذي
ضحوا به من أجل القيام به ،
فأنت تعلم أن هؤلاء ليسوا
أشخاصًا مستقلين لم
يعملوا بالخارج أبدًا  من الشركة العائلية
أه تعلم أن أموالهم هي أموال العائلة
وهم
بمعنى ما يدمجون أنفسهم
في جدول أعمال والدهم